un revenu pour tous distribués tout au
long de sa vie sans contrepartie c'est
l'idée du revenu universel
jeudi 26 mai l'association initiative 78
organisé un débat sur le sujet une
soixantaine de curieux ont fait le
déplacement pour assister à cet échange
et c'est l'occasion pour nous de pouvoir
rassembler tout le monde autour d'une
table autour d'un repas convivial et de
débattre de sujets qui pourrait on va
dire être effectué au sein de
l'assemblée nationale ou dans toute
autre instance et là on les aborde
sereinement avec comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure des personnalités de bord
totalement différents mais qui sont là
aujourd'hui justement pour débattre et
construire ensemble
frédéric lefebvre candidat à la primaire
de la droite et benoît hamon conseiller
régional ile-de-france du parti
socialiste ont partagé leur avis une
première pour benoît hamon qui ne
s'était pas encore réellement exprimés
sur le sujet voit dans ce domaine ma
religion est pas tout à fait fait et ce
qui est clair c'est que si je devais me
prononce en faveur d'un revenu
d'existence
ce serait pour qu'il relativise la place
qui est celle du travail aujourd'hui
dans nos vies ce que je pense que
il a pris une place démesurée au point
qu'on juge qu'on ne puisse s'épanouir
que par le travail je pense que forte
heureusement pas s'épanouir 2000 autre
manière qu'on travaille en est le revenu
d'existence peut peut-être et contenu
les rapports nous disent que dans les
dix ans on va détruire trois millions
d'emplois de plus il travaille va va
muter on est en pleine mutation est donc
le seul moyen aujourd'hui de s'adapter à
la réalité de l'époque c'est de changer
de modèle et le modèle que je défends
c'est le revenu universel qualifié
d'utopistes par ses détracteurs le
revenu universel fait pourtant son
chemin dans plusieurs pays la finlande
est prête à tenter l'expérience avec un
montant inconditionnels de 800 euros par
citoyen selon l'insee en france plus de
8 millions de personnes vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté